une fouille encore celle-là pour
l'histoire direction le château royal de
blois étudié de long en large connu pour
son escalier françois 1er il n'a
pourtant pas encore livré tous ses
secrets
des archéologues viennent de mettre au
jour des vestiges du vieux de plusieurs
siècles avant le moyen-âge c'est un
nouveau pan de l'histoire du château qui
s'éclaire hélène chapelet c'est une
salle du château de blois qui n'avait
jamais été fouillé depuis trois semaines
philippe inspectent la terre à la
recherche d'un 10 avec deux autres
archéologues ils creusent sous les pavés
de la salle des maçons avant de refaire
le carrelage de cette pièce ouverte aux
visiteurs ces professionnels doivent
évaluer son potentiel archéologique des
échantillons de blocs de terre vont donc
être prélevés pour ensuite être analysés
en laboratoire
car cette terre très foncée pourrait
bien dater de l'époque des gaulois
quand on est sur ce genre de terrain en
fait on peut faire appel à ce conte
on appelle donc une étude micro
morphologiques ce que même les petites
infiltrations d'eau les appelle pas oui
les infiltrations d'eau peuvent se voir
dans la terre microscopique m'en parle
en voilà on voit si voilà s'il ya eu six
là il a plu pendant une très longue
période dessus on va le voir voilà et si
ça a été recouvert d'un bâtiment mais on
le verra aussi
voilà donc c'est c'est plein de petites
informations comme ça qui nous
permettent de caractériser de
caractériser les occupations successives
aux sept premières inspections devrait
donc permettre d'en savoir un peu plus
sur l'histoire des lieux le seul plan
concernant les différents bâti du
château date de 1576 avant impossible de
savoir à quoi ressemblait le monument
que l'envi sur ce évidemment d'en savoir
plus
voilà parce que c'est une sorte d'
enquête policière me retrouver des
indices et ils pouvoir reconstruire
l'histoire et nous tout ce qu'on va
trouver et ce sera tout de suite
exploitez utilisés dans les visites pour
des ateliers pour les scolaires pour
différentes animations
à l'issue de ces premières recherches un
rapport sera rendu pour déterminer s'il
est pertinent ou non de prescrire une
fouille plus étendue en attendant à la
fin de la semaine
les trous seront rebouchés avec la terre
trouvait sur place